I'm very open about my identity. I, uh, my
Hmm.
Father actually comes from a Dalit Christian background, uh, Dalit Christian identity. My mother comes from a normal Dalit identity.
Uh, but she kind of followed a Hindu faith. Uh, so like, in our home also there's sort of a mixed, uh.
Hmm.
Uh, cultural situation. My father kind of like, uh, he's a writer. He would also always tell stories and also wrote many stories where like, uh, he would talk about like, uh, how of course, uh, especially for Dalits migrating to cities like, uh.
Uh, renting was a problem and he used to tell this in during his childhood also when, uh, when his father like had to, uh, move out to another village for work, like, uh, there also like finding a place was very difficult to them, but he tells that like a Muslim woman.
Actually kind of didn't see caste and kind of like allow them to stay at her place like for rent.
Um, so, uh, yeah, so he tells me like since childhood like he saw many of these problems. For his masters when he came to, went to Hyderabad from his village like there.
He tells me like when they couldn't find hostel or something like there also they would look for places where they saw a lot of problems. Like for example say like people would ask like like Andhra Telangana being of course they're very
Uh, caste-based kind of places, like every other place in India, uh, at least in North and South India. So he would kind of, uh, like there would be many ways like people would read, uh, you know, people would want to read caste, like.
Uh, it's like they'll ask your surname. Uh, they'll ask, uh, they'll kind of ask vegetarian or non-vegetarian.
Hmm.
Uh, like, um, so there, there are many ways, like, uh, I mean, uh, they would kind of, some people would directly ask, some people would say like we would give it only for Brahmins or like people who eat only vegetarian.
Yeah, some people are like, like, what are you and my father was frustrated and yeah, we come from an SC background. Then they would say like, oh, looks like you look like a nice person like.
to whom I can rent it out to, like I feel like that, but you don't seem like an SC person, like how does it go? Like as Dalits also, it's like, you know, coming to cities and getting mixed up in all these, you know, schools and
workplaces and other public spaces which everyone kind of share and partake in. It's like you don't think about your identity much, right? At least for Dalit and other kind of people. It's like suddenly
Mm-hmm.
Hmm.
When you are asked to, you know, kind of, uh, kind of demonstrate who you are, that's where the problem starts. It's like, it's like that's how, like, of course, the discrimination kind of shapeshifts follows through in this pattern, like.
It's like that.
Can you hold a dignified sort of identity like even after you, you know, kind of disclose who you are and all of that and.
that and
I actually initially thought like maybe in Delhi like my father, I mean, of course his experiences are his and I don't know if it will be as serious here or I don't know if people can really like
I don't know.
Hmm.
I don't know, like caste also operate, the way people read caste and kind of bother caste also differs, right, like there and here. In 22 like.
Uh, when I came back, like, uh, I had a stipend at hand, and so I thought, like, uh, enough of double-story Vijayanagar kind of a thing, let me take a bigger place.
Kind of.
Mm-hmm.
Let me take a 1 BHK and let me kind of little afford something little bigger and comfortable so that like my father also can come and stay with me and all.
I then started looking out for places and the first thing a broker asked me ki what's your name like are you a Muslim or something. He's like no no I'm not a Muslim.
But I'm not a Hindu either, like, but what's the big deal about it? He's like, uh, nai nai yahan owner log Muslim log ko nahi leta hai. And, uh, this sort of a thing I realized like in master's time also, I think when the CAA protests were happening like, uh.
Uh, some of us passed on like, you know, pamphlets of like about CAA and what is what it does to people like Muslims and like all of that and all and we try to kind of create.
some anti this thing and all and all. but like the entire area Vijayanagar and maybe that applies to like all these areas on this side, this part of the North Delhi. I think where like most of these areas are also kind of partition.
Mm-hmm.
Uh, refugee areas like where I think people, uh, who came from Pakistan kind of first kind of settled in these areas, like most of them, all of them mostly like upper caste, dominant caste, uh, kind of Hindus like who came and settled here. I think that kind of, uh,
Experiential thing also kind of follows through where like people are already kind of by default communal, but with the context of whatever they went through themselves and all that.
So in MA time like when we were sharing these pamphlets like some people were kind of you know expressing nahi nahi nahi yeh CA bilkul sahi hai and they would talk all these very Islamophobic kind of things.
Uh, so like I had that kind of, uh, memory a bit, but, uh.
Uh, the first major dominant question, truth be told, I was asked like when I was looking for houses, uh, throughout this time was, uh, like, are you a Muslim and what's your name and all. First thing, uh, the first tick box they want to check, tick is, uh, like Islamophobia.
I think casteism came later, that I should like first honestly tell. Like my name also, like this kind of a name, like with things like my parents wantedly put because.
Hmm.
Like for example, my father's side, some of them had Christian names and they faced a lot of problems. Like, I mean for availing reservation benefits also, for availing SC status also, that is one thing. But at the same time, it's like in Andhra, Telangana, most of South India areas, if you are a Christian means...
The same.
It would tantamount to equalize, it would equal that, like it would say that like you are also a Dalit, like. So because most Christians out there are Dalits in South in Andhra area, like.
Christine.
So, so my father was always scared about this, so he he was like let's put proper Hindu names like that that sound very that kind of goes with the caste Hindu sort of a thing. My name was a big shield. Not many people asked me like
Uh, cast directly like what my father used to tell. The major part of like, uh, this feeling of like I don't belong sort of a here is like, is this very vegetarian Brahmanical vegetarian culture?
You know that even Jains, I mean I think most Jains only like kind of were like Jain owners were asking like are you veg or non-veg? Non-veg lok ko hum nahi dega. Like then I used to ask like where do you live? Like ha we don't live here, our this place we are renting is here but we stay far off like.
It's like then what's the problem of like me like, you know, cooking meat in your place. They were like, no, no, no.
Uh, even in a place like where we are renting, like we want people to be vegetarian and all. Then what, uh, will eggs work? Like they are like maybe eggs work, but, uh, don't at least like kind of expose them to the outside or something, something, something they would like, I don't know.
So, directly like I don't think like I've seen like a caste caste sort of a thing, but indirectly I've faced a lot of things where
Uh, sometimes, um, like there would be a change in behavior of the owners, like when, when something more about my identity kind of, uh, was gleaned by them. Like, uh, say for example, I stayed in a
flat of the first flat I took that only. Where like I think they saw once like they came inside like to check for like you know repair or whatever complaint I had and they want to kind of
take a look at it and see like how things are going to, I mean how what they can do about it. I think they saw an Ambedkar photo at my home and and he was kind of glaring at it for some time and then he left like then he left and later on like
They used to kind of make me sit inside like whenever I visited their place to pay rent or something, but this time like they put my chair outside their doorstep. It's like there's a bed closer to the, um, I mean there's a bed closer to their front door.
Like the woman used to sit there and she's the landlady like.
Uh, she used to sit there and like used to talk to me like, uh, later I realized like many people like would come to repair, many working class people would come to do repairs in their place like plumber or.
Uh, this person or that person, but if, if, uh, if his assistant or someone like, uh, used to go and fetch something and he has to wait, like then used to, they used to put the chair outside the door and make him sit there only. Like I could see like they kind of.
Uh, replicated the same thing with me also, like.
So, thankfully like this incident happened during the last few days or last month before I was kind of coming out of their place, vacating their place. So, I mean, I was like
Good that like this kind of a thing happened now or else I would have been very traumatized to continue in that place like. I was Ambedkar photo I'm kind of fine and chill with like I can happily like just put it in.
they can make any assumptions and this thing and that thing. Uh, I was
I mean, I cook meat at home, like all of that is there, but
Uh, yeah, but this this scare was little there if, uh, sometimes my friend Sidhra used to come, she used to bring Nihari and all and we used to eat at home. But, uh, not like so much of a scare or something, but a tinge of like, uh.
Attention of fear also comes, like I don't want these people to come and like check on me or something, something.
But it's also there's also like something like, no, I I I want to be like as much free in in my place and baad mein dekh lenge like what happens etcetera. But that sort of a small small like not fear but like it's like ki I don't want.
You know, I don't want these people like coming and meddling with me, what is happening this and that. Thankfully some owners, most of them are not interfering at least in these matters as to like what are you doing and all of that and all, because later on I
Hmm.
I rented out homes also in a more, you know, professional, elderly sort of a capacity because I told I am like a PhD person which is also like, you know, I'm working and this thing and that thing. So like they kind of gave me that kind of a
Uh, I mean they didn't at least like kind of saw me as a student, child kind of thing and they saw me as a proper adult only. But yeah, like these are some of the things like I could relate, I could kind of think about like if you ask me like any sort of a, you know, direct or indirect like.
Discrimination or, you know, difficulties, you know, if your identity kind of like...
Somehow is outed to people in different ways and whatever ways and all.
Hmm.
Like that is one sort of a thing, but general problems with owners are like a lot, like irrespective of which identity you belong to, yeah. So like after this first home, after exiting this first home where I was narrating this incident of
Putting my chair out and making me sit outside, sit outside. After this house, like I later kind of brought in a flatmate also, where I started looking for flats like along with her.
Hmm.
Uh, she was my junior in Ambedkar and we, uh, I mean, uh.
Uh, of course, like there will be different problems of that kind when you tell like a girl, a boy moving together, but we kind of posed as we are brother and sister and cousin sister or something.
of course.
Uh, so that went fine, but what happened is we finally saw home, like she was coming from Kerala or somewhere.
We finally saw a home and it was like my exit date of this home was also kind of all round the clock, like it's like approaching very sooner and I was like, oh my god, I should find a home before I'll be homeless like.
So that hurry was also there and I was searching for homes and
So, um.
I mean, searching for home for two people, like, I think by that time she came, I should, my date was already very close to a wicket, so I was like, better I'll search for a home like very sooner.
Bye then.
There's a place we found with it's like a 2BHK and all like in Vijayanagar or elsewhere many places like finding a 2BHK where both rooms like has I mean if there are two bathrooms and both the rooms has windows and ventilation.
Oh my god, like if you have one thing you will not have another thing. I think that's a reality. Yes, yes. One has to settle with wherever they go in Delhi, like yeah, if you have one thing you can't have another thing, that compromise one has to make.
That's a reality. Yes, yes.
Uh, I can't speak for much about South Delhi, but in my North Delhi exploration, like this thing, compromise is always something you have to adjust to it.
Like so I looked for this home and I told them like I and my sister are gonna stay here like she's gonna come in some time and all. And that place like you know it it seemed fine, it seemed fine, it was a good place, we are paying good amount of money on it and all.
Uh, there are many things actually like an owner could do. I mean, um.
Hmm.
Like say of course, like yeh toh sab log bolege ki owner log kanjoos hota hai, kuch karta nahi hai, bahut kam paisa deta hai, like for you know doing whatever white wash aur doing any repair or something that is of course like that is there.
Mm-hmm.
And, I mean, if at all we can talk about this, it's like how worse an owner is. Like, so yeah, that thing is there where an owner would hardly kind of like spend a penny on like, you know, making the flat better. Like if you are giving thousands and thousands of money like,
They could of course spend hundreds like, you know, to make things better at home, but no. I actually like I was also a little amateur then. I gave, I checked the home and I thought I told them like, you know, these these repairs, these these cleanings are needed. And I should have kind of
waited for them to settle and kind of repair and give me a like good clean comfortable.
proper like ready to move in type of kind of a house, home. I wonder, yeah, I thought like if I should have waited till then before I could give all that 1 month rent and advance and all.
Hmm.
But yeah, like because my date was approaching, I was also in a hurry. I gave like 1 month rent, 1 month advance of like both mine and my friend flatmate like was also supposed to move in. I gave literally like some ₹50000 or something like 1 month rent and 1 month advance and all.
Uh, but I was telling him I need all these repairs, like the home is big and nice, but like, of course, like without all these things, we can't move in right away.
They're like, okay, okay, let, uh, we'll do what we can, like, I mean, we'll do what we can meant that, like, we will not do that much, like, that is what they meant and, uh.
Hello.
That is.
Yeah, like, so when the day my flatmate came, like, turns out that the cupboards have a lot of demuck. A lot of demuck, a lot of termites and all of that. Like, I was checking these places, but I didn't check in that detail.
That we realized like all the cupboards at home is filled with themat, like it scared the shit out of us.
Mm-hmm.
I mean, either these guys should replace them with better cupboards or like we should just move out of here. It's like so it's like the house, entire building is owned by a landlady, a very old woman like who's also like kind of
Uh, who's kind of suffering with some illness or something. It is her daughter and her daughter-in-law, like these two women are kind of talking things and managing.
you know, renting situation with us. So when we told about DMak, they told, okay, we have only one solution and
Soon.
They both came with two hathodas, two hammers, and they smashed all the cupboards.
Okay.
They smashed all the cupboards, smashed all the cupboards and
kind of like, you know, wherever there is remark, like they smashed all the cupboards. Then they brought in a small, a very like not even a professional guy, not even a good painter or something, they brought in some guy and they gave him like some paint and like, you know, you just
Uh, paint all these places wherever the cupboard is removed. Now without the cupboards, the home looks like, uh, you know, a skeleton without a body, muscle, dress, nothing. Like it's like it's very bare and, uh.
Paying like fucking ₹25, ₹26,000 for this place, this kind of a place without any cupboards like.
kind of a place.
felt very like silly and very atrocious like we went and told them, you know, we can't stay here like this is if this is what you're giving us, we thought you'll do something about the cupboards by modify revamping them or something, but they're like no no no no.
Like we have your money, like either you want, either live for 1-2 months or like you just leave right away, like nobody's stopping you. They like kind of, I mean our nuts and bolts and fuse came out when.
They told ki like no no no we won't return a single penny like. Some 50k plus like who would lose it like. So we fought tooth and nail like the fight went on for 10 days. For 10 days I was homeless like I was jumping between one friend's home to another and.
Like, yeah, we did so much drama in 10 days, like they did so much drama in 10 days, like the old woman, like she was, you know, all talking nice and this thing and that thing, like towards are bachche hai, yeh hai, woh hai, in a sort of a
Uh, you know, sort of infantilizing, molycodling kind of thing. But when we told this news, she all hell broke loose. She's shouting at us.
Mm-hmm.
I mean she's kind of throwing two, three gaalis also at us and all of that and later on like she started crying ki like we only depend on rent. You know, as though like
It's like, you know, only depending on rent is making them victim or something like, of course, they're fucking like landed property owning people, they're fucking privileged, so.
and is making.
And of course,
It's like, you know, just because we asked our, we didn't even stay a single one or two days, like. It's like, yeah, we gave all that money and they're acting as if like we have taken their money. Three brokers actually looked for a place and three brokers like together pulled in and gave this place, no? So,
Uh, other two brokers were like, you know, we, uh, other two brokers, we also will not like lose our, can't lose our brokerage. We, we have showed you so many homes.
Hmm
Why didn't you tell us then? And those two brokers also kind of left and they didn't return their brokerage also. Thankfully, there's only
They only shared 50% brokerage. The other broker was a little sympathetic towards us.
He's like, you know, I'll
Hmm.
Negotiate with them and for 5-6 days like we also fought and
They were okay to return 1 month rent. That 1 month rent also, they might return if someone else comes and stays in this place, someone else comes and moves into this place like other party.
So like, my me, my flatmate and my flatmate's partner also, we have devised some, like these guys obviously like showed a lot of their villainism, like let's also do some.
Uh, you know, uh, let's also like, uh, do something to save our asses. So we actually, what we did is we, uh, we, uh, we still had the key, so we created a duplicate out of it.
Mm-hmm.
We created a duplicate out of it and, uh, we kind of like, uh, I don't know, that was, uh, it also didn't do much, but we, we, we were like, let's also do something to kind of, you know, secure ourselves against these people. We don't know whom to trust anymore.
Yeah, so, yeah, like no, of course, like in that shithole of a place, nobody came and like we had to lose the one month rent we got, either we got one month advance or rent, whatever, but we got one month of money, half of it. And thankfully this other broker, who's the main broker, like
He was actually kind of, he's a little sympathetic and he gave away all the brokerage to us. I don't know, that also like very miraculously happened. So in that sense we lost a lot of money, but we gained also like, I mean we got back.
Advance.
Ha, little more than half of the money.